- So wait, speaking of
motorsports, we saw this photo.
- [Chloe] Yeah. Yeah.
- [Kelly] That, so what,
what are you doing there?
Was it like a test?
A dare if you could hold it?
- Oh, for sure.
No, I mean I, I went to
the Austin Grand Prix.
- Yeah.
- Which is like the, the
Circuit of the Americas,
which is really cool.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- With Williams Racing.
And I wanted to see if I could pick
up the tire 'cause it looked really heavy
and I did it, and it wasn't
quite as heavy as I expected.
- [Kelly] Oh wow.
- But it was fun, yeah.
- [Kelly] Was that so much fun?
- Yeah, it was a lot of fun.
I really, really love, I love Formula One.
Especially since the show on Netflix.
- Yeah!
- I like got really into the drivers
- and knowing their kind of backstory.
- I love how active you are.
(Chloe chuckles)
You love to just be so
active and out there.
- Yeah. Yeah it was fun.
- [Kelly] You like
adrenaline, you like the rush?
- I do like adrenaline, yeah.
- [Kelly] I'm so opposite.
- I would totally drive a Formula One car
if I could, if I possibly was allowed to.
- I would totally cheer
for you from the side.
(audience laughs)
- From the side. You can
be, you, the checkered flag.
- I will be your water girl.
- You can have the checkered flags.
- I will hold down that water bottle.
You'll be like, "I'm so
thirsty." I've got you.
- I've got you.
- Like, yeah, I'm not into,
I did the NASCAR thing once
and they drove me around.
It was Jimmy Johnson
and it was so fast. I
was like, we're good.
(audience laughs)
- They go really fast.
- Yeah, they do.
- And like the G-force from the circle.
- [Kelly] Yeah, they do.
- Yeah.
- I was like, Jimmy,
Kelly's not so into that.